from CNN outside of the criminal charges
and prosecutions were saying there is
another path the Democrats may take to
try and win in 2024 and that is mandates
and lockdowns first from CNN first lady
Jill Biden tests positive for covet 19.
and I have to wonder why report this
story why did the White House think it
necessary to tell the world they could
have just done nothing they could have
said you know Jill's taking a vacation
no they wanted the world to know that
she is positive for covet 19.
well a lot of people immediately
speculated this is it it's how they
reintroduce covid politically at the
start of the election cycle guess what
everybody Joe Biden announced something
like 25 million dollar ad spend it is
beginning you're going to start seeing
all the news stories get planted you're
going to see political contention you're
going to see criminal charges you're
going to see conspiracy theorists you
are going to see it all because after
this we got another story
Biden tests negative for covid will wear
masks when close to others White House
says and thus Begins the normalization
of everyone wearing masks again now Joe
Biden will be wearing masks in all of
his videos we've already are all the
videos that he's in all the uh press
statements and everything he gives
you've already got schools and hospitals
bringing back masks now the president is
doing it and lastly Dr fauci concerned
people won't comply if masking
recommendations return I hope they abide
I love the story because fauci was
saying the CDC doesn't mandate masks and
uh what he said was they recommend them
it's actually the states or the private
sector that mandate The Masks so when we
talk about mandates coming back you all
need to understand it is going to be the
chain store or restaurant that says
based on the recommendation by the CDC
you now must wear a mask when you come
into our store that is how they will
bring back mandates and they will say it
wasn't us who did it we didn't lock you
down the stores are choosing to do it
yep a keyword private sector right the
airlines are going to implement this
when the government says oh remember the
last time we bailed you out it's not
gonna happen again unless you uh make
some changes your policies so the
private sectors has the is their arms
being bent by The Binding Administration
so that's their tool to you know enforce
and get these things through to the
general public Tucker Carlson said he
doesn't think that they're going to do
the mandates again
but uh more and more evidence starting
to pile up that they're gearing up for
lockdowns now the other news of course
ladies and gentlemen this may come as a
shock to many of you Whoopi Goldberg was
absent from the view that's right and uh
because she tested positive for copen
there was a second one too the one of
the other ones tested positive
apparently what if all the view ladies
have to quarantine because they have
coveted what do they do then
let me uh let me play the video for you
guys this is uh we have this from Alx on
Twitter listen to the reaction by the
audience of The View when they get the
news that Whoopi has covet and Joy Behar
claims it's back okay
um as you can see Whoopi is not here she
has covid
back but she's on the mend she's on the
tail end and she'll probably be back
this week but week but sorry she's not
here for those of you who are looking
forward to seeing her it's back they
never left it's endemic like they made a
point of saying it was endemic like it's
here forever so there it is you know I
just feel like the culture war is
divided amongst people who seek out
information to challenge their views for
the most part not always and those who
desperately don't want their views
challenged at all and just want to be
told what to do
the people watch The View
they just want to be told what to do
yeah what to think what to feel just
tell me when to jump I don't know I want
to fit in it'll be easy and then
everyone else is like let me figure it
out for myself
you brought up the point from Tucker
Carlson that he does not believe that
mandates are going to come back he did
say that he'd be willing to bet his
house that we're going to enter a hot
war with Russia and that Biden's going
to use that as footing for the election
to manipulate control however you know
they see best fit but I'd rather have
this I don't I don't want to have
anything but I'd rather have this than
hot war with Russia yeah I think both
might be true yeah it could be I mean if
if we get involved in hot war with
Russia let's slow down even Tucker did
says we are at war with Russia that we
understand but like a formal actual
confrontation you know full scale or
whatever if that is to happen that's
what they'll do to try and win yes and
if that does happen where Biden comes
out there's gonna have to be some kind
of attack on America it's gonna have to
be whatever whatever may be a legitimate
maybe a false flag I'm saying before the
US can actually formally engage in any
way I'm not saying formerly declare but
engage there's got to be some public
support that results in a lockdown they
will have to control things with an iron
fist in this country if they're going to
engage in direct conflict with Russia
but I don't know if they can I mean if
that was an audience of just average
Americans when uh the the ginger lady
when she said you know it's back you
would have heard average Americans laugh
that's what you would have heard that's
not your average American right there so
how do you impose that if most of
America is not on board
I guess it's a question of will enough
people just ignore it or not it's fouchy
are his fears correct that people will
not comply look I got to tell you out in
West Virginia you know if they if that's
just not going to work you're not gonna
get it it's not gonna happen they can
try in Maryland yeah in Maryland it'll
definitely happen because the people in
Maryland it's just it really is
interesting this divide
there are a lot of people in Western
Maryland who are uh you know it's modern
country
but then you go to the businesses and
they are on their knees begging begging
the government to tell them what to do
and it's just like weird you cross that
River and then they're just like we
don't care what you do it's just there
are different cultures that live next
door to each other perhaps it's because
you know Baltimore more resources more
money more likely to be enforced people
are terrified West Virginia yeah you're
not really going to see Heavy
enforcement so people just do whatever
they want and say I don't care dude do
something okay when we when during the
lockdowns and the mandates we I went to
uh uh Marilyn's Panhandle there was a
bar in the middle of knowing that a sign
on the door being like you know masks
are required as per state require
regulation or whatever and then you walk
in no one's wearing a mask and the
bartenders just like washing a mug and
he's like looking left and right like
you know shruggling like whatever dude
nobody cares but to the closer you get
to uh DC the more the businesses are
terrified screaming at you and kicking
you out I think it happens I like they
want to lock down the conservative
Boomers during the mass mandate period
because I knew so many would wear like a
mask off their ear and be like they
should have had to wear it but I don't
want to like there was this funny
resistance around there are certain
people who complied they wanted you to
wear four masks and then there were
other people who were like this is dumb
and I don't want to be doing it and how
effective can these masks really be uh I
think some of the issue will come down
to the state Governors I think we I mean
one of the reasons we all know Rhonda
stands his name is because he was like
yeah we're not doing this and he
deserves a lot of credit for that I
think this time around if there were to
be some sort of pressure for mandate
states there would be a lot of Governors
who now see that if they say no they are
putting themselves in favor of the
majority of their constituents it's all
about the vision you know in the lead up
to uh you know 2020 if
East Tennessee did not look like
Portland you know there was not the same
protest there and it's all about the
vision and this time they're probably
gonna have some sort of a lockdown or
mandate or whatever but it's going to be
by area to create the vision and just
cause unrest and Chaos right before the
election again I'd love to see uh the
inter-us migration change too like if
there is a second lockdown that was one
of the biggest Trends I mean U-Haul was
constantly reporting this that the the
places people were leaving were places
that were more interested in enforcing
mandates I mean this could be a way that
especially rural States see a population
boom that they are not expected to get
but it's very hard to with the economy
the way it is and these interest rates
you're how are you supposed to leave
right now I'm not saying it's easy I'm
just saying there are people who will be
like I'm not doing this again this is
worth the investment well I think it was
very easy to say that the first time
around with the housing market just
being an actual absolute boom now it's
very it's much harder I shouldn't say
it's very hard everyone's got different
circumstances but it's a lot harder than
to just be like here we go to West
Virginia a lot of people can be stuck
with in areas that are mandates we saw a
lot of people leave places like
California and uh New York and Illinois
and go to Texas and Florida I'm
wondering how that affects their state
these states are not swing states by any
stretch any stretch of the imagination I
wonder if you know Texas is was turning
purple now it's now it's red Florida the
same thing
New York Illinois and California were
never going to be red so these moves
they're making are actually helping
Donald Trump and Trump only lost 2020 by
42 000 votes between three states if
more people start moving to I don't know
Wisconsin Georgia or what's it what's
the other what's the third said Arizona
I don't see how Trump loses I I mean
look Californians are moving to Arizona
and these and these are more moderate to
left-leaning people who are fleeing
their own policies and they're going to
bring it to Arizona and they're going to
vote in to make things worse
Wisconsin I'm wondering are people from
Chicago leaving and then going to
Wisconsin voting for the same thing
there's that famous tweet where the guy
was like I'm leaving finally finally I'm
leaving California it's bad I'm going to
Florida and then people were like you're
going to Florida but Rhonda hence is bad
he's like oh don't worry I'll keep
voting the same way
it's like oh okay and then you're gonna
turn Florida into California yeah thanks
so much for your support yep when it
comes to these uh the talk of government
mandates I feel like this is once a body
develops an immune response to a virus
it just is totally ready for that virus
the next time it comes around and this
mind virus of everybody get ready to be
afraid get ready to hide in your house
from this invisible thing like people
are immune it doesn't mean that we're
impervious to it but people are done
with it they don't want the
they're done with being told what to do
they're done with sitting in
their house being told they can't go
outside they've had it I it is permit
this this Society is resilient I'm I'm
not convinced I I witnessed it when you
go to when when I would go to DC or or
Frederick in Maryland and you would see
these businesses drop to their knees in
two seconds perhaps the people who Moved
feel the way you're describing it Ian
but now those people are in Florida and
they're in Texas and they're in West
Virginia the people who stayed are going
to do the exact same thing govern Me
Harder Daddy I was I was very positively
uh influenced by being at the airport
and seeing how few people actually had
masks a couple of weeks ago yes but
there's no mandates there's like six
people there's no mandates I was at the
Library of Congress today and they had
the big rotunda where you know only
researchers are allowed no one's really
allowed in there with all the the books
and documents and stuff there was only
three people in that massive area now
these are supposed to be like smart
intelligent ivy league people that get
to go into that room two out of the
three had masks on so bizarre it's
insane every one of those people in The
View they're saying oh no the mandates
are coming back coverage coming back but
I guarantee you they went home and
started to pull up recipes for you know
homemade you know loafs of bread again
as they're waving their Ukraine Flags
it's like these people are happy they
want to see it happen because they love
the control
people that are really intelligent but
very low wisdom they're very good at
being told what to do and immediately
doing what they're told and mimicking
and remembering and then you know
playing back I I'm very good at this see
now reward me I'm very good at doing
what I'm told those are that's the
danger of intelligence you know people
love reading on their neighbors people
in these cities are gonna are gonna be
vile they're gonna join the mob and if
the mob says mask they're gonna say a
mask and then they're going to celebrate
anybody who dying who doesn't stuff to
make this conversation from the top I
mean just to top down like talk about
other people because I think people my
guess is that if anyone feels as
remotely as fed up with it as I do that
there's no way in hell this is going to
get off the ground again I barely had to
touch the masks people people's three
bro people didn't like it in the first
place yeah but they thought they were
doing good in the first place now they
know there's fear I mean people were
told if you come anywhere near your
grandmother she'll immediately die that
was like it's the same amount of
information it's not even that it's that
the government came and issued fines and
arrested people a woman who was who is
selling her products from her store on
the internet on Facebook had the cops
show up and threaten her with charges
unless she stopped doing Facebook live
the reason these people cave and gave up
is not because that they all of them are
celebrating it's because these cops are
going to come and they're going to beat
the crap out of you there's a salon how
many salon owners like two or three got
arrested a guy giving haircuts in
Michigan got arrested a woman in uh what
was it
she fled Minnesota to Iowa and then the
sheriff tracked her down and arrested
her because she opened her coffee shop
during lockdowns there will be some
people but that terrifies people so you
you go to these big Urban these big
cities where it takes one guy to destroy
your life by destroying your business
and these people will drop to their
knees in two seconds and say we will do
whatever you say government except the
government really up last time
the cops are going in there it's pisses
me off so much man the cops would go in
there and be like you can't open your
business the people be like yeah I can
and they're like No in fact we're doing
what's good for you we're shutting your
business down the person's like now I'm
out of money the cop's like good we've
done our job like that doesn't you can't
you can't do that to someone twice you
cannot they they've already you've
already shocked everybody away but the
the cops uh either quit or fired the the
ones that were on the side of Freedom
I'll say right I mean we had mandates
not just to wear masks but also to get
the vaccine so it's like a lot of people
said no and they lost their job over it
those cops are gone we don't have them
the cops that are still employ Lloyd are
ones that are just doing it for a
paycheck or said yes government I'll do
whatever you want look at these videos
of how they arrest these j6ers it's like
there's some just like a dude there's
like a video of a guy going to a grocery
store or something and they run up with
like rifles pointed at them like dude
these These are drone gestapo morons
working for these agencies they don't
care they don't know it feels good to be
in charge of you it feels good to them I
mean these are these are people who are
not satisfied by their own
accomplishments or they're they're
Satisfied by feeling like they can do
whatever they want to you that so what
ends up happening is you get a small
business and they might say something to
you like I really hate it but I have no
choice they're gonna find me that's what
everyone kept saying and I I see this
now we talk about it quite a bit James
O'Keefe had a really great tweet and he
posted it on Instagram and he said you
are responsible for whatever life your
children inherit that all of these
people who are saying I can't stand up
for what I I believe in because I have
kids and they're putting my kids at risk
then you are directly responsible for
what what the lives your children
inherit when they are living under the
boot of Communists who are laughing at
them the party members who get special
favors or food it's going to be because
you you allow this by saying you know
I'll just I'll just I'll just comply
I'll just I'll just give in I'm not
saying I have all the answers I think
typically
you know I think come 2024
the reason we're seeing a lot of this
Extreme Action is because if Donald
Trump's right as of right now if the
election world today Trump wins that's
what the polls are saying right now
that's what the analytics are saying
that's what the forecast models are
saying it doesn't mean he does win but
that's why you're seeing the machine of
the Democrats panic and need something
to force people into fear or you know I
guess more Extreme Action when I look at
these videos of the j6ers being having
the feds come up and point guns at them
like they're hoping for some kind of
reaction from from these people don't
give it to them all you got to do is
just
make money succeed push back and resist
where you can and then make sure you're
spreading the word as much as possible
there are a lot of people who are like
there's this weird game where they're
saying Tim's saying not to do anything
no I'm quite literally saying resist
where possible succeed make money build
influence build culture and then come
2024 get everyone you can to vote an
overwhelming numbers Trump only needs 42
000 votes and Biden's going to lose a
lot more than that that's not a
guarantee that Trump fixes anything it's
not a guarantee that Trump actually
comes and saves the day at all but it is
a start I think that's what they fear
that's why they want a reaction and you
can't give it to them
yeah we got to govern ourselves outside
of politics that's for sure Ian I got a
question if you've been traveling a lot
all over the country recently with you
know let's say for this year so far in
2023 what happens if they start bringing
you know they bring back mask mandates
for trains and planes what I'm curious
to how you'd handle it because it would
derail your life or you'd have to comply
well I try not to answer questions with
premises I don't agree with and I feel
like accepting the premise that there's
going to be a shutdown if this makes it
more likely
different from Mass command I just
stopped flying I'm almost I'm about
ready to stop traveling anyway but yeah
I'll just completely stop shut that
sounds private only you know a lockdown
a covered lockdown is very different
from mask mandates the mask mandates
seem very likely there are still
businesses all over Maryland with signs
saying You must wear masks and those
colleges in Atlanta were like just put a
mask on I mean there are some
institutions are already rolling it out
in some capacity so it doesn't seem
impossible that it'll spread I just
think it'll be very Regional I think
that there will be you know certain
sectors of the country that say yes and
certain that say no and you know I hope
that everyone gets to live in a
community that reflects their values
um and I think Tim's totally right there
there is it's sort of like testing the
boundaries there's going to be a push to
have to see what you will be okay with
and what your reaction would be and you
have to just stay in control as much as
possible it'll be interesting because I
think if the Biden Biden already saying
he's wearing masks it does please a lot
of partisan liberal types but it will
push away moderates and Independence so
in that regard I don't know how this
plan is ultimately going to help them
unless they're using it to ramp up some
kind of new expansive voting policy for
2024. it is kind of late though we're a
few months away from 2024 and the the
election Cycle's already begun so any
rule changes will have to come really
quick they can do it quick New Zealand
Australia whatever they they had those
uh coveted camps and blink of an eye you
know things could change very quickly
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time